I was gonna try and not be tired again
but I guess it's it's already 11:00 yes
yeah it's too late for that okay but
we're back I think it's recording right
yeah yeah yeah okay we just finished
round two except just finished we
finished round two like four hours ago
oh yeah a little while ago now you had
dinner angry two or three hours ago for
me it's been a long day the rounds got
rescheduled yeah this is the first time
it's ever happened I've never seen that
all of our rounds hasn't pushed one hour
later I mean I've been at Chicago open
they're round like starts late because
they're disorganized but this round just
we found out was rescheduled so yeah
anyway we had some interesting games and
hopefully we'll we'll try and be
instructive I'll try and be more awake
than yesterday I don't know if how
that's gonna happen but have like a 60
70 move game yeah we had much tougher
games today and then yesterday what we
can start with my game let's do it okay
so I was playing I was playing white
here against a player read around 2000
am Bru Dan Kallen and so I actually
played my favorite f3 lion against the
Kings Indian and we get this benoni type
structure eventually here I felt like
white was doing pretty well I would say
this is probably like the critical
moment in the game at least a very
interesting one if you guys want to
check out the actual opening moves and
you wanna get the PG end of the game I'm
just gonna plug it every time you should
check out my patreon page where I'll be
annotating all the games from this
tournament my other tournaments as well
as giving some some detail on the
opening okay that'll be in the video
description yes looking for links will
be will be there well so here black had
a decision to make because white house
pretty serious start over k7 Queen has
to move or a tix g7 king takes and then
f4 just winning two pieces for the rook
so clearly block has to do something
about this threat
my opponent I were both calculating this
move Knight d3 because it looks very
sharp Bishop is hanging with check and I
actually this turns out to be fine for
white but during the game I didn't
realize I was just miss counting the
pieces sewn I take C 1 this is kind of
blacks idea White has to take on f8 and
then if he takes on YouTube with check
then white is just very happy Knight
takes and then material is equalized
while I will put the knight on d4 Queen
h6 and blacks position is really weak
strategically I feel like White is
usually better in this kind of position
but that's not always the case
but then during the game I started
figure out what to do after this move
Knight b3 where he hits the Queen again
and he hits the rook if I play like
Queen h6 you would expect would be the
move then he just takes the rook and my
bishop is stuck and I have absolutely
nothing but I realized I could go Queen
f4 and then I was trying to figure this
out during the game because if he takes
on a1 I can just take on d6 and then I'm
skewering him if he gives this check
I've Bishop c5 and so this looked
tremendous for white but then after I
figured he might tell you it's crazy
line I figured he might play Queen b6
check in this position uh-huh so it
looks like because he gets out of the
skewer and then take the rook and then
Bishop takes d6 and in the game I
thought I would be down a full rook here
so I was just miss counting the pieces
I'm only down in exchange and so why
it's just completely winning just like
amazing position Dartford bishop i
thought maybe i pick up the night and
i'm ok right buddy
so he turns out I can't really go for
this but I thought it was quite an
interesting line I walked by around this
point and I saw another of those lines I
just saw your a file I thought you were
better yeah yeah I got this be foreign
right so he went with the I think a
normal move f4 I'm just shutting down
the position so I inserted rook a 7
Queen d8 and night h2 it basically my
feeling here is that if Black gets kind
of no play on the King side then it's
only white can really be better because
I just have be a file I can put a rock
on a5 and just hit this b5 pawn
so I felt like strategically White is
doing well but concretely I think the
engine here is is totally fine with
blacks position I don't know it was an
interesting fight queen g5 king h1
Knight f6 he wants to come to h5 and g3
I played nine g-49 h5 King gage - and
then you took which I thought was
surprising because I felt like here if
he just plays Knight g3 I wasn't clear
what my next move is gonna be I don't
really want to take on your safe right
like he has no breakthrough
yeah I always play this game what's this
threat I don't think he has any
breakthrough would like taking on e2 on
g4 and I'm trying to feel like h3 or
something but it's also hard for me to
move because he always has like Knight
of three tactics so I have to keep the
bishop defended that's annoying and can
you play like just rook a one rook see
seven in case a seven or something yeah
this would be my plan considering if he
has no threats which just assuming you
have unlimited time right so do whatever
yeah I think actually it's pretty simple
like if he takes on g4 we transpose to
the game basically so I guess I don't
really see another option for him at
this point other than taking and trying
to do something well that makes sense in
any case he this way he takes her first
I thought his idea was actually to play
h3 which is a little tricky move but I
think I can just take it with the pawn
and then like Queen h4 I'm just rug
Jiwon and I didn't see that he can
really do anything so serious here it's
definitely annoying but I am I felt like
I should be fine oh as long as I'm a bun
during night take C 2 + o night if one
check of course yeah I have to watch out
for this trick the double back to that
night Forks yeah yeah I definitely saw
this during the game I was so fixated on
like getting a rook to a chain and
platon Queen to gauge three rookie yeah
that that crossed my mind I was just
very happy for my rook here to cover the
F sevens right there's never any picking
f7 okay rook g2 is not again
but maybe something like Bishop f2
should be yeah be safe
should be good okay he plays he just
puts night on g3 rook a one and now
Queen f6 and so this one was very
annoying because he's threatening Knight
takes f3 discovery and the bishop is
hanging I was trying to make this line
work bishop f2 but of course the night
is on c3 is also hanging and then after
94 and takes to play rugby 7 mm-hmm but
it doesn't feel like it's quite getting
there like Bishop d4 she is like rook f7
and yeah we're rugby 7 yeah or he can
put the Queen on h7 and right and so yes
I was looking at this but I didn't see
anything any follow up so I think I'm
just down down in exchange my bishop on
e2 is just not a good piece in in any of
these lines but then I found I think the
only move to kind of keep the pressure
definitely a good little positional
puzzle if you guys want to pause the
video and try to figure out how I should
deal with the threat of Knight f3 or
19th g4 because of course I don't want
to just play rugby one and and be
passive I want this work on the a file
okay well I moved the kink I cheated I
planned stuff like what's the move oh
well but you saw the game also I think
you did but yeah it's like I mean it I
noticed the move almost immediately cuz
you always think about okay can I just
move my king and get out of the check
but obviously you have to make sure that
you're not just like getting maded here
because he has all kinds of ideas now
like Knight takes d4 Knight f2 check and
I got to make sure that there's no no
mate but but there isn't what eventually
convinced me is that on h2 it's like
well he doesn't control this square so
on h3 he still has to take both of these
squares under control so as long as the
H file doesn't open up then I should be
fine as long as it's not bughouse yeah
and then any move like Knight h5 I can
just ignore it in most cases so I don't
have to worry like takes
five something so I felt like I felt
like I had a grip here I didn't even
know what move he's gonna make but maybe
we can just quickly run the engine I'm
just curious what the evaluation is the
people won't see it but we can just kind
of announce it that equal debt equal but
zero point zero zero sometimes means
sometimes it just means that computers
confused yeah Aronian said exactly that
if it's zero point zero zero it means it
has no idea okay so basically saying
equal after every move my played rookie
a trying to raise White's like you have
all the active player yeah it feels like
what is doing fine
oh actually you know what okay we'll
turn the engine off there is one moment
that we should probably analyze as
humans because it was it was interesting
so yeah I'm just like keeping the
pressure he plays Rick b7 which is the
best move but really passive and now I
really wanted to take the pawn enough
for but the problem is Knight takes f3
and he has this in between check on G 1
so if I just take the knight he takes a
dark square bishop he's probably much
better so the critical line would be
Bishop takes g7 he throws in this check
he would take on e 2 that's crazy
Queen h6 yeah just takes yeah exactly
this is the problems that he's always
ready to just take and cover everything
that's too big and so I just don't think
any of this is really working for white
the best I can do is just like take the
knight and I imagine I'm I don't know I
think black should should be getting
counter play here pretty soon so that
was unfortunate I couldn't take the pawn
but I decided to pull back just bishop
f2 force them to play g5 Queen a2 and so
here I felt like well only white can
really break through you know assuming
neither side blunders now you control
the only open files so yeah life is good
but the problem in this position is that
well I simply can't really improve like
the pawn on d5 I can't get another
attacker
and the problem is I have to constantly
watch out for my knight on c3 is always
hanging to these tactics so I just play
Queen a3 because I was taught that when
you're playing a weaker player and you
have no advantage you should just do
nothing well you have a lot of time in
the world to as long as you keep things
defended yeah small improvements but but
then I was thinking like okay if he just
makes any move here Bishop f6 I wasn't
sure like I can play rook a six Rick a
eight can you somehow maneuver your
Knights tied down into the bishop I want
to get a knight to d4 of course I mean
the only would be like Bishop d1 yeah
like Bishop d1 but this always allows 93
so I just have to be careful about this
I see not that 93 is always a huge area
Rose I just want to demonstrate
especially Queen a - okay let's imagine
he plays Knight d3 we put the bishop on
one and then we maneuver the knight from
b1 to a3 to c2 to d4 and find some nice
weaknesses yeah it takes a lot of time
but you know but sometimes I mean if he
if he literally has no moves then then I
would have time for this hmm and this is
a hyper thing like maybe the computer
doesn't find right as computers don't
aren't creative yeah it'll be
interesting maybe later all like I'll
analyze the position a bit deeper yeah
and then those annotations will be on my
patreon page you should check that out
yeah it's definitely that would
definitely be useful but I imagine
concretely he can just like cuz once my
Knight goes to like a3 you know you can
start pushing the C pawn I don't know
yeah there's always gonna be some
technicalities but but his problems that
the knight on G 3 is very much it's not
really doing a whole lot so it's kind of
misplaced
it's the decoration yeah exactly but if
it was on like d3 then you know black
would be better but well in any case I
still feel like the best he could do
here is just nothing but he takes on e 2
which I think
was a gift because that's just the
plaintiff here right so his idea was
this 93 Bishop D for Queen h8 he was
trying to take over the dark stories I
don't think it quite works and we'll
look at that but the engine I think on
chest 24 so I don't know how good it is
but it pointed out that 93 is actually
in the mistake had black plate c3 here
he gets counter play which I didn't even
consider during the game that's a hard
move to find yeah so threatening 94
mm-hmm and if you take with Queen he has
some discovery yeah exactly so I don't
know I assume I probably could take with
the Queen can you play rook 8th and take
with night yes I mean we're okay
a Queen's he said he still has some
discovery yeah
I guess there could be some endgame like
Queen 63 Queen Dixie three night takes
III might take G for maybe White's still
better there because you take with King
and g5 things yeah well yeah this looks
very nice for white like take bishop D
for just your for me game over so I
wonder if maybe he has something c3 is a
type of move like you before you play it
you have to copulate lions like right
you have to already figure it out yeah
maybe takes a 93 maybe this is just not
to not to let the king in yeah the
knight is awkward to defend maybe rook
c8 hanging also oh yeah I didn't see the
knight was hang yeah so Heidi won only
move 91 and rook c7 so I mean black must
be like hearing your kid c1 or page one
yeah exactly so I I didn't think about
it at all during the game I haven't
thought about much now maybe I just take
with the Queen just to play it safe
cuz 94 I don't know how much I'm worried
about this one right like should be four
yeah your knight could become a beast
later
yeah mine is no worse than than his rook
yeah but maybe he can take on g4 or
something I don't know something like
this
I still like whites yeah it still take
white here right yeah but I can see why
this could potentially be like equal
according to the engine
cuz now my king is more exposed as well
so he has more ideas if I give him Queen
d7 at some pointers right yeah in the
game after 93 was actually just over
immediately um which I really like about
these this f3 structure cuz sometimes
black equalizes but then a certain point
you just get this grip and it's just
fantastic so now if we trade these
bishops than my knight just gets in and
so I'm just completely dominating
everything in Queen h8 he missed my
response here actually good time a
little puzzle for you guys to pause and
try to figure out White's best move here
I cheated again but I thought coming so
tight think yeah okay it of course and
black just doesn't have any good
response to it so the problem for him is
that after rugby eight I'm gonna play
Rick a7 with a pin so bridge e8 just too
passive I didn't even consider this yeah
any of if I thought 95 is more likely
and then I would take and I thought this
position was just like beautiful just
like Knight coming to c3 complete
domination just all pieces are I was
reliable and really hoping for this
forever pin I mean yeah I just learned
just the gorgeous blockade unfortunately
for me he decided to sacrifice his queen
which objectively he probably should do
at this point but my queen is just too
active I it to be a little bit careful
here because whenever my queen takes on
d6 for example he wants to play like
rook a seven rook a one rook h1 mmm-hmm
wooden I have two ideas yeah so I have
to be I have to make sure I'm not just
getting mated here so I I play king h2
prophylactic move and he pushed c3 I
took on b5 hitting his Knight and now
he's just not in time to really create
threats
pick up everything and make sure you
plan on for a while here but I mean this
is already game over
so yeah tough game good good job but
interesting like strategically and I'll
be interested to see a little bit deeper
with the the engine thinks about some of
these lines
yeahbsolutely like double I just like
these these structures scare me like
this Hamish oh right but no near Kings
Indian it was kings and EMU border okay
but with Samish and black boys c5 I see
and but I've I've played this kind of
position alot so I feel at home here
yeah shall we move on to your game let's
do it yeah it's super late so we're just
gonna this is a long game but I'll try
and get through it
look yesterday I said I'll get through
the game quickly and it took like half
hour uh-huh this game is 76 moves let's
whip the board I was black I went
outside my comfort zone I played a
something I've never played before
it's like g6 I move one actually no
that's a lie I played this once before
against Michael Moyer to get my eye on
norm I played this line C 4 C 5 T 5 5 5
and that was weird but I won the game
anyway um you're playing also mm rated
player yeah I'm playing some young girl
like 14 years old I felt that I I
couldn't remember her name I still can't
remember her name it's one of these
Romanian games which I don't know how to
pronounce but when I got to the board
I forgot what to write down as my was
like that was an Oscar but then the
round was starting like right before it
started so I was trying to look at like
her score sheet to figure out her name
but she was writing in cursive anyway
let's get to the game huh we went into
appearance defense which it's completely
new for me
I knew I was gonna play this before the
game but I really did very little
preparation I just wanted to get some
position yeah I was getting inspired by
Nakamura huh and I saw she played this
in one game on I should have prepared
like the c3 move but I I guess I was
lazy I chose to just take a walk and
listen to music we watch her cast videos
also good yeah anyway I but I did take a
look it's like some g6 games well I
didn't actually well I did before the
game was I searched the position after
d4 g6 and just looked at the top games
okay and one of the games was a Shroff
game and I saw this e5 idea so why not
c5 yeah especially with the bishop on g7
c5 combines well but no any ideas you
know so anyway game continues rook e1
Bishop g4 usually when black plays
Bishop g4 the goal is to trade off the
bishop eventually so my t2 is a good
move knowing not at some point want to
take on f3 knight c6 h3 we trade and
then I wasn't sure what to do there's a
few options I can take on d4 I can play
e5 I played what I thought was a nice
kind of pressurizing 7 that seems right
yeah just attack d4 3 times and I was
interested because she thought for a
while here I thought maybe she would
play Bishop e3 I was interested about
potential lines with Queen b6 I wasn't
sure what I was gonna play here as Queen
b6 maybe she can take on c5 it could get
weird very quickly no I can also play as
some key 5 and we get some more closed
structure
d c5 would you take on b2 there you
think after Queen b6 Queen b6 yeah I was
trying to figure out what's happening
right I was just thinking on her on her
turn because I had nothing else to do
yeah then I realized okay if she goes
into this and I'll think further but I
didn't want to take so much energy
trying to figure out this position yeah
honestly one I don't know I mean no
offense to low rated players but there
move surprised me so much that I almost
stopped thinking on their turf because
like you know it
at some point they're just gonna pick a
move it random and that's essentially
what happened okay maybe it wasn't
random but she she played the move which
actually made me really happy
d take c5 which I think was just very
comfortable for lack or does she's
basically giving up her Center my knight
comes in and she played Bishop III so I
took away her bishop pair and then we
got this position which now it's like a
Sicilian dragon yeah and White has no
Yugoslavia rhiness and I have one or two
students who play the Dragons so I'm
actually like used to going over ideas
and use dragon structures Queen a5
typical move next several moves I play
quickly locate a c8 I didn't want to
trade Queens and she played a5
I don't know what she was doing maybe a
six and you know trying to get some
positional play so I played a six which
I knew gives her the B six squared but I
thought that it would be valuable for me
to fix this pawn on a dark square just
because we have dark spread bishops
right and any pawns I get fixed on dark
squares should favor should favor me so
anyway uh sort of a positional moment
sorry sometimes it's something go weird
okay Queen g5 then I played east six
which probably wasn't at all necessary
and I think this is maybe a turning
point I'm not sure exactly what happened
because very soon I got worse and I had
to untangle I really wanted to cheat and
put my knight on c4 I just couldn't
figure out how to get there
I've only path is ninety five and then
she trades Knights yeah so I don't know
maybe another kind of move is like 98
I played east six thinking I was gonna
play like rook ft8 and d5 but it didn't
quite work out the way I wanted it to as
we'll see the problem in the dragon when
you move your
pawn and you have a pawn in g6 it's just
a big weakness right and then it was
actually hard to play d5 you know it's a
357 rook t3 and I realized my deep pond
she's about to play rook a d1 and
there's gonna be so much pressure and
you never have worked e8 right because
it should be six yeah I can't play rook
to e8 cuz this be six square so I
realize I'm just getting outplayed like
the whole a5 idea works great for her
given that I committed to e6 so I'm I
don't know what I should have done
better I was trying to reflect I
reflected a little bit during the game
if we actually go back to when did I
play Queen 8513 yeah I was reflecting
that maybe I should have gone for like
some immediate Knight a5 and then maybe
Queen c7 nicephore where it's just a
clear plan and it's low risk but anyway
that didn't happen I had to deal with
problems and here I realized okay
troubles happening so I have to do
something so I play pawn to e5 which
then it becomes tactical because if if
Queens get traded there's all these
lines which I'm not gonna remember but
like if she takes I think my plan was to
take take and then I don't want to wind
up with isolated pawn so I was gonna
play some move like 97 or 97 and try and
be tricky and regain the pawn wait why
can't you just take here with what in
this position
oh I'm sorry yeah that's not an extra
pawn that's a yeah that's uh do you have
like Rick cd8 or c4 c4 is usually not
with Bishop take B - mm maybe you know
work cd8 as Bishop B's right yeah so
yeah I spent a lot of time trying to
like figure out these lines like d6 and
my knight moves somewhere I was trying
to figure out all of this before I play
d5 and I realized okay I should have
enough resources I've never rely on
intuition I just play d5 and make her
think yeah and then she played the
strong move Bishop c5 hitting my queen
had to go back Bishop d6 hitting the
Queen again and then R okay do you want
so she's just building up pressure like
she didn't go for those may be more
concrete lines she was just going for
for pressure and I had to do more weird
stuff played 97 what else to do had to
defend d5 then she played Bishop c5 now
she just wants to win a pawn like Bishop
taking 7 and take on d5 I mean put
training mode I want you to cheats do
you see the next mo I did no no okay for
the YouTube audience I don't know if
this is a good move but I think it's
it's an interesting exercise blocks in
some danger a lot of pressure black to
move here what would you play what are
the candidate moves yeah reminds me of
my game from yesterday in difficulty uh
yeah and you have to do something weird
right - yeah create chaos on the board
f5 did you you play that fight I play
the castles an f5 yeah I played that 5 -
there we go
when in doubt play a 5 Wow and it's a
weird move I'm sure she was not
expecting it oh so you if takes honey
seven years want to take on e4 exactly
it relies on this tactical trick where
if this works happen everything works
out well for black capture attack and
Wow
and and it's just better for luck so
your pieces on these squares amazing
it's yeah I was inspired tonight goodbye
checkers so anyway um white still has
options here she played the move which I
thought was second-best she played
Knight g5 I think she should have just
taken on d5
new variation because now I would have
to I think I had to take back with night
and I thought like white should be
better here somehow with this structure
like e6 in f5 and some day rookie 195
there's this forcing continuation c4 I
would have to play she maybe I broke
c7 rook DC 7 but I was that Knight f6 oh
I thought white should be better in some
of these lines but yeah that's why I
went for it like I still have options
and White has to navigate through some
chaos so anyway um but I don't like I
don't like c3 here for white our c4 c4
because like you have this perfect
structure yeah I like rook e1 there
makes more sense if it's if it's
playable the the point of c4 is to chase
a knight to f6 to make use of the e5
square and really move like 95 yeah
which I was trying to calculate but
maybe it's just like positioning good
for whites but you have like Oh Mike
take in 94 yeah I forget what I was
thinking maybe this is just okay for a
black actually well I don't know what to
say yeah III haven't analyzed this with
engine um cuz I don't want to make
myself feel bad so just save it for
another time yeah uh but anyway she
played Knight g5 this game is like a
whole story like it whole book can be
written about this game oh and we're not
even like a quarter of the way through
or a third of the way through no we're
just about a third of the way through
so anyway going forward here we trade on
e4 she's threatening that d6 I played
that at 5 now I felt I started to feel a
slightly happier white should still be
better given Black has three three pawn
islands a lot of potential weaknesses
but at least my pieces are
so game continues a lot of these moves
just came instinctively like Bishop F
fates just wanted to keep improving
queen c8 realize that there's some
pressure on the C file and the set up is
a bit awkward for for white but I
realized instead of Queen C AIDS right
after I played it I realized maybe I
could have played 96 with idea of 94
putting your piece on the dark swirl but
to get to another two gets to a light
square exactly I wanted to take
advantage of the bishop upon b6 okay so
I started thinking about this sign after
I played Queen see it and then I
realized that I can play rook e1 and if
Knight c4 I think there's this move
Knight take v6 because of this pin so
then I was happy because I'm Queen C is
actually useful and prepares 96 all
right so anyway I played Queen C eights
with a threat of 96 and then she played
C for some of the structure changes
again I can't take on c4 because Brooke
to rook d8 would happen and my queen
would be trapped so I play d4 getting
continues between C to e 5 and now I
start putting my pieces on dark squares
or at least my paws on dark squares
which yes I mean I have to sign her
phones and she has no Center pawns so
why not push them their ship g7 h6 well
you can't take on c4 I wanted to take on
c4 but then I get triple for it g4 uh-oh
wait a minute yeah I think g4 way the
minutes I definitely saw this 94 rook
takes c4 yeah I think g4
you don't have rook c2 or it doesn't
matter because you're still getting
fourth done I think I'm still getting
the fork that's a problem of like a
triple fork for threat but maybe I have
like nine h4 and I'd have three ideas
yeah
Queen c60 so wait why reject this rook
takes e4 I thought there oh yeah I
rejected this a very clear-cut reason
Bishop c5 ah I Brooke get stuck Wow
it's actually very strong move well I
was actually calculating those lines I
think the game was so long I just yeah
you're getting all of it anyway so I
play h6 preventing Knight g5 r1 at the
tip on my queen on e6 so I put my Queen
96
she plays b5 now the game transforms
even more cuz stuff opens up on the
Queen side
I thought she wondered why when she
played rook b3 I thought she just missed
rook c7 him I'm winning something on the
C file but then like she was very
resourceful she found in this counter
play with B take a 6 I can't take the
bishop right away and initially I wanted
to take with the Queen on a6 I spent a
lot of time here wrenchy I took it upon
because I thought that okay I should be
like winning more stuff because so many
things are attacked yeah but she has
rook b6 Queen take a five and then rook
takes you seconds g6 I was trying to
calculate this because if I can get away
with winning material it's worth it
right but I don't know her attack looked
really scary after rook takes c5 Knight
f6 check this is unfair position for
stock fish yeah and I was looking at all
the different King moves
like one example line is King h8 and
then Queenie for and I realized she's
threatening like if I move my knight
there's wrote a gauge six and queen h7
means yeah so anyway I thought it was
scary and then if King f7 is queen h5
which is also write terrifying yeah so I
didn't go for that let's go back I took
with pawn smart and then let's zoom
forward because yeah more stuff happened
stuff got traded more stuff got traded
and then I got some initiative I put my
queen on g5 starting to feel like okay
around here and then she played she
played a move which I saw but then she
follows up with the move that I didn't
see yeah I okay so I saw Brooke take g7
and then I was looking at Bishop taking
five thinking that okay black still has
some chances I didn't see Queen to e5
well I didn't realize I completely
forgot she could force a queen trade and
win the d4 pawn oh and she takes d4 oh
it was sad yeah how did you win this one
I don't understand you'll see it was
okay it was a nice endgame grind we were
okay we were both in time trouble here
we were both holo five minutes I have
about five minutes and she had like
about a minute so the time control is
just 90 minutes plus 30 second increment
no second time control just nice it's
kind of short but that means once you're
in time trouble you just for the rest of
same time trouble
yeah but the 30 second increment like
it's not easy to play on in these sort
of definitely favors some pirate player
games yeah
so I was relying on some experience
anyway okay this should be a draw
because whites whites down the exchange
but it has two pawns for it yeah and the
fact that white can trade rooks okay so
I avoid the over trade I don't want to
try your ups I play rook c5 now when I
play trick c5 I just assumed I'm winning
the a pawn
the bishop can't defend but then she
play the move I completely overlooked
and we did she play that I I didn't
think it was possible I was just having
some weird hallucination
wait yeah what does why put here because
it's just such a simple move - it's just
Oh F for trying to get rook d7 check
with counter play um but then I win 85
and at least I wind up on hmm wait -
moving basically hold on - like hold on
to all the fonts cuz check King e6
I was expecting to work out for right I
think Vergara is good enough yeah she
did something simpler just Bishop f4 she
counter-attacks h6 oh yeah and she wants
to play Bishop T to rent and then when
she played this move I was sad because
like I'm not even winning the eighth on
and then I have to like commit one of my
King side pawns and she's gonna trade so
okay so I played g5 yeah now I'm still
playing for a win like I have two rooks
and I know like from past experience the
two rooks against like rook and Bishop
it's deceiving like sometimes these
positions look dead wrong but it's
surprising how much like how many tricks
can exist right and that's essentially
how I want just same tricks so Bishop
you too yeah because I imagine the fight
can just get the bishop to like b6
then it's some it's a fortress a
fortress right but yeah that's not easy
to do
well yeah White has to make some
concessions sometimes if white tries to
hold on to everything and then there's
some like some plan for black to break
through but anyway we'll see what
happens rook b5 I only get both Brooks
to the second and like the one targeted
in this position is this Bishop on d2
which is not the most stable thing so
she brought her King in which is logical
my truck here gave me one and then I
played you're okay too
uh with I forget what I was thinking I
just want to put my rook on the most
active square yeah and then she actually
made the mistake here she played a move
it's still drawn but it made me a bit
happier she played h4 which I think
losses upon well its attempt to simplify
right but she's being a bit too forcing
yeah and I think she just missed a
combination I just take and after wrote
a cage for it looks like I'm just losing
H pawn but I'm actually winning a pawn
here
Oh Ricky fat check uh Ricky five
probably Bishop III
oh just Bishop III yeah Oh Chuck wait
rookie five Bishop III thought I would
have oh it be five Bishop d2 back yeah
well I guess check rugby two and rook
takes a five yeah and this is kind of
what I was hoping for earlier is he got
some tactic where I pin the bishop and I
can take a 500 it worked out beautifully
because like I'm not talking the bishop
with tempo she has no time to take on h6
only move to save the bishop his room t4
and then I take on e5 it's still drop
but at least I was happy early I was I
had some momentum going my way and
amazingly in the momentum continued and
yeah just like this H pawn is not at all
impressive white should be able to build
a fortress no problem but then I don't
know hurricane got a bit awkward maybe
starting with King d3 she should just
somehow um how it's possible but like g3
and put the King on g2 yeah and put the
bishop on e 3 inches weights right rook
F for wreckage hold on
Mertz imagine but I can do anything
there right so I think King g3 maybe a
bit inaccurate and then I started doing
things first of all I had to improve I
had to defend my H pawn she played
Bishop III g6 m g3 so now she had the
plan she had the plan of bringing the
king and gotta stop it
hold the mouse so I have to stop it yeah
only move to stop it is rook f6 and then
I had some like positions like this you
have to be very creative you have to
think about all the potential ways you
could win the position and like after
she played g3 I saw this this potential
King March like Sunday put the King on
f3 even if I like even if it's still
drawn I want to invade the light squares
right and this did eventually happen
because her King is awkward on you for
so rook c4 rookie - I'm going for
cheapos here because she has she was
always hovering like around a minute she
saw it
move back she moved back and then I
wanted to go for the same cheapo but I
want my rook on me one and it actually
worked out nicely I played rook e1 and
she was just waited and then I played
rook e1 mmm
with the same cheapo but no King g3
doesn't attack the rook right and if she
plays King g3 which I don't think she
did then I would start I would try and
like improve my King right somehow and
someday try and get to f3 yeah oh she's
yet right so she play the passive move
here rook b2 which then opened up the
possibility of the king h5 once ideas of
king g4 it should still be tracked but
um game continues king e5 we got fades
King g5 I don't know why she played King
oh she played King g5 to get off the
e-file and then I started thinking here
because I have some options by I also
have stuff to be worried about because
she has ideas over of b6 and this pawn
is weak right and I have Canada moves
like rookie a rookie a the earth t1 and
then I realized in this position I could
potentially checkmate her within three
moves
three is a very key mating idea which is
important for I think the best move for
black is to start with D D one check
most natural move for very nice and play
King G for I'm threatening made in one I
was like I was so happy but it's still
probably drawing but at least okay I'm
threatening me than one because the
rooks and the King work together yes she
can't take on h6 right
13850 king e5 may be playable so I was
happy to find this line because then I
have just enough time to play h5 right
I want the pawn on the light square yeah
yeah King e5 is interesting like there's
so many ways that position can branch
out wherever the king was for a walk and
that Brooks trying mate yeah I think
from a practical standpoint it's may be
preferable for black right of course
it's always preferable for black but I
would have winning chances here it's
amazing like she like voluntarily
brought her King out probably thinking
it was the right thing to do but I just
kept her King on g2 the whole time it
would have been a lot a lot easier
defense for her oh yeah I don't think
she should have like how long today pawn
what she did just like yeah activate the
rook anyway um
she played rook b5 and still here I
thought it was gonna be the draw but
then I saw some line which actually
happened in the game that's a winning
line I don't know if it's actually
winning I'll just go ahead and show
rookie eights uh involves trading rooks
which it felt wrong just because I only
have the H pond but I thought that like
I didn't see how she responds after h5
because King e4 is the most natural move
and then after rook e1 I think she's
just since long oh she just has no moves
and there's I guess a few key variations
here
of course what happened the game she
played King g3 but if she moves looking
back to e5 then I just take on e3 and I
will I'm too fast cuz her King is
blocking the pawn so I'll still have to
check with the engine if this is winning
or not this is seven pieces this would
require the paper you know base are you
just trying to take on f2 at some point
yes so yeah that's the whole winning
idea for that goes to some days second
f2 and then Queen H fun but the King has
to be kind of far away well you'll see
the king was still relatively close was
able to do it it's King g3 he got three
and then she played King G - oh well and
then I just went wrong - exactly as if
she takes like her king got her king has
still yet somehow defend that pawn or
get to f1 but yeah it's not ever happens
the key move here is Kim G - so I took
on f2 and she was sad and she played
Bishop f4 then I just played rook G -
threatening rotate g3 yeah any move
exactly I guess I can't pre move it just
in case she plays g4 but then she [ __ ]
so yeah that was my game it should
should have been a draw I was probably
worse like somewhere in the middle game
after f5 I would think even those four
words there but yeah I've was able to
complicate things enough and then like
these middle game positions where she
got counter play on the B file it was
weird
there's a lot to analyze yeah and I
think this is a this felt like a long
analysis but this was very very much
longer game so yeah that's a long game
but anyway it's we started almost an
hour ago I think so Wow
almost midnight five minutes till
midnight yeah pairings are up for
tomorrow do you see her
Chloe I'm playing um I think a candidate
master like 21:40 I'm playing a
candidate mastery - oh okay so tomorrow
I'm playing an 1800 rated I'm master mom
okay he's 12 years old so he's scary hmm
okay I think we're gonna end it there
yeah tomorrow's round is at 9:00 a.m. so
we need sleep all right guys
yeah thanks for joining in